parce que j'ai un petit cadeau en plus
pour toi et pour toute la famille je
pense que ça va vous faire plaisir
est ce que tu veux bien appuyé sur ce
bonheur au ce que tu veux que ce soit
maman qui le fasse mais vaine
allez-y appuyer toute la famille sur le
buzzer et pendant que vous appuyez vous
allez regarder l'écran que j'ai un petit
cadeau pour vous regarder
attention c'est parti allez-y niche
allez-y
op
assuré
mecheri
les séries d'abord
oui
-
nous espérions les chéris des seuils ben
laden vous l'avez concours grâce à notre
partenaire ce soir vous avez une maison
à vous h m on va remettre symboliquement
les jeux on peut remercier le choc hier
par la ci dessous bien merci
alors barbelés et 102 me voilà c'est
voilà merci donc vous pourrez habiter
dans votre maison voilà c'est que c'est
un beau livre les clefs de votre maison
vous allez pouvoir milliers de familles
ont à nouveau bercy
merci vraiment merci chance et c'est
très très difficile de retenir ses
émotions en tout cas je tenais à vous
féliciter et toute l'équipe d opérer
ravi de vous offrir ce projet et je
demande à tout public de faire une
ovation parce que cette famille
américain
passer de commercy
série
chéri d'amour à cherry toi quand tu
étais tellement heureux problème a été
touché par le témoignage de votre maman
vraiment ma chérie tu m'as tellement
touchée je suis tellement heureux pour
toi je sais qu'il fait tout pour tes
enfants tout pour eux c'est vraiment que
j'ai fait j'ai pensé à eux
on a demandé de remettre pour saab à
noël il fallait remercier il fallait
parler avec son coeur
donc j'aime j'ai demandé des cadeaux
pour mes enfants
un sapin pour eux en fait qui sent que
noël il ya le père noël existe et je
savais qu'en demandant à baba noël
ben je réussis mon noël